hey guys this is andrew from
trainingsenses.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and right now
guys i'm doing youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge and
i want to show you guys what kind of
tools and techniques protrader is
actually using
and what is efficient and what is
working for me and especially
how you can use it so if you want to
know about all the stuff and basically
how to make money on the market
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make an update on
rocket rkt let's get into it
[Music]
first let's have a look at the chart so
i'm on a daily time frame
so in the four hours time frame let's go
back to the daily time frame
i like to start with the daily time
frame because it's the most uh used one
and if you go to the
stuff that is the most used by the other
traders you're gonna have the best
reactions all right so on the daily time
frame guys
so first thing you we can see is that we
had a breakout of this resistance
how did i find this resistance i
connected the two recent highs that i
had here
very important guys you need to be on a
logarithmic scale otherwise your trend
lines are going to be different the
levels are going to be different and
basically you're
not going to have the right levels on
the logarithmic scale i connect the two
recent highs
and this is giving me oh surprise 24 as
a breakout level and this is exactly
what we had to break out
then the market went insanely higher and
we corrected we then have this
retest guys and for those who are
watching my videos we
always like in 99 of the time we have
this kind of a situation breakout then
re-test and you don't buy the breakout
guys you don't buy it here
so many people bought it here you can
see the volume so
basically the volume increased a lot
let's go back on the flowers time frame
how many people bought here you know and
all these people that bought
around 30 35 you know now they feel
super bad
so and you if you didn't buy it yeah you
feel super good because now you have a
very nice
entry level and you can also see that
here you have this kind of trend you can
make this kind of trend line
so here you have a double signal that is
giving you a bullish trade
so what kind of trade you could do here
you can buy at 20 you know between 23
so once the resistance has been broken
it becomes support guys this is the
basics of technical analysis so 23 is a
strong support
but what i see here guys is the
situation that i've seen many times
before
that is usually quite explosive on the
upside
so i'm gonna have a look at the short
interest but i know it's high and
short squeeze is likely to happen here
so you buy at 24 you stop loss at
21 something like this so you have 10 15
percent you can lose
we can easily go back here and probably
gonna go higher so maybe 100 100
so this is a very nice risk we will
trade guys
so very quickly to understand what
happened here so of course this was a
hot stock this was very popular on wall
street beds on yahoo finance everywhere
even on google trend you can see it so
i've got new finance i tried to find the
news
and basically they published some data
and
so what did they say that's recalled one
day again kept
more than doubling in three days up 109
after the company reported better than
expected false quarter results
and announced a one-time dividend so
special cash dividend
of one dollar share the company doesn't
pay a regular dividend so guys this is
very good news this is very bullish this
is healthy
uh this is gonna actually make the show
the hedge funds
show the position cut the position so
they probably uh cut it
here in the in the move up they probably
were buying it here guys so
it's not only retail uh investors that
are buying probably hedge funds as well
and let's have a look at the short
interest guys so i'll go on
uh market bit and on market watch and i
cross
check this data so here on market watch
you can you just type your ticker rkt
and you can see that we have 40 million
of short interest so compared to the
outstanding number of shares
this number shares outstanding must be
equal roughly to this number
so here for example the public float is
higher than the shares outstanding
so you know that this is not updated
this is probably correct
the total outstanding shares is probably
higher but it's
roughly the same whatever we have around
36 percent of short interest guys it's a
lot it's more
more than amc more than gme guys then i
cross check this data on market bit same
thing
and here you can see that uh we have so
the float size 108 all right same
and the number total number of shares
short shares is the same as well so we
have around forty percent of short
interest
a short squeeze is very likely to happen
and one more interesting thing is that
you can see that companies like morgan
stanley
analyst uh reiterated reiterated the
equal weight
rating she initiated coverage of rocket
and you can see some news like
morgenstern nasdam so
blah blah lifted his price target to 24
dollars
from 23 all right so he's very
conservative he still doesn't understand
those new investors they don't care
about the fundamentals at least
it makes it a very nice level to buy
for people who follow fundamentals so
this is and look guys
23 24 once again so this number
is everywhere because actually it's
coming from the flows it's coming from
technical analysis even this analyst
he doesn't really maybe know why but the
number he found
is actually coming from uh the same kind
of indicators i think
so uh once again i repeat we have a very
very nice bullish trade to do with a
beautiful risk
ratio of around ten levels to buy 23 22
24 25 even 27 guys you know and stop
loss at 21 something like this
and you can make a very nice profits
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys